a lot of students are also using video
conferencing apps now as their classes
shift on line zoom is one of them seen a
huge rise in its user numbers in fact
it's been downloaded more than 50
million times on just the Google App
Store in the past few weeks governments
have also started using it too and as
the US produce software gains popularity
the company's now facing questions over
its privacy it's even been accused of
passing information about its users on
to Facebook let's talk about this with
Adrian Mars IT consultant and technology
journalist on skype from London nice to
see you Adrian
we should hey we should point out that
g20 virtual meetings and top-level
government communications are not
happening on zoom' they obviously have
their own secure lines but the British
government has said yes we're using it
as a inter-government communicating tool
in your opinion is it quite unquote safe
I think it's a bit worrying we're
getting mixed messages from government
the Ministry of Defence have said to
their people in the UK
don't use zoom while we investigate the
national cybersecurity center a
different arm of government said hey
it's safe as long as it's not used for a
really high-level secret stuff I'm sure
the the government have some extra
layers of security on top their networks
will be some to some extent one would
hope insulated from the outside world
and there will be tools to monitor where
data is going but I think it is a bit of
a worry it has a poor security record so
quite a few months back the Mac version
of zoom security researchers discovered
a flaw that allowed anybody to to pick
up video and audio from a zoom cam and
they took months to fix it and that's a
terribly bad sign all software has
security flaws all you can really go on
is how well the manufacturers handle it
right and in this case they were
terrible I also noticed on Zoom and
correct me if I'm wrong but you can be
invited to join a zoom meeting and you
get an email from the invitee and you
click it and it takes you straight
through you don't even necessarily have
to have downloaded the app or have an
account with them that doesn't sound in
my very simple mind that's secure yeah
the water there's a similar floor where
people were hackers were randomly
generating zoom meeting IDs using a bit
of software and just seeing if that
meeting existed so they could drop into
meetings at random they fix that and I
would urge people who are using zoom to
set a password for their meetings so
that will prevent that sort of flaw from
from being exploited I'd also urge
people if they're using a desktop
computer with a plug in webcam when
you're not using the webcam unplug it if
you're using a laptop cover up the
webcam with a piece of tape and just as
important sticker dummy plug like a plug
cut off an old pair of headphones into
the microphone socket and that will
disable the built-in microphone inside
the laptop it's not just zoom when
computers are exploited hackers will
often listen and record what's going on
on the webcam and the video whatever
software oh yeah I mean that's just
that's just good advice at any time I
think isn't it more generally I mean
obviously VoIP voice over Internet
Protocol programs are being used so much
more right now does it follow them that
there will be a strain on them that
there will be service outages just
because they are so popular at the
moment and and bandwidth is being
stretched I think the general sign is
that for most providers at least from a
UK perspective is the bandwidth isn't
being stretched they've got lots of
capacity people are using more bandwidth
but that actually most providers have
more than enough it's absolutely fine
when more seen problems at the server
end of things so the Internet itself the
connections are fine but some people's
servers the these things that live in
huge data centers in big sheds around
the world are being stretched so the UK
version of Microsoft's cloud services
called Azure that's having a bit of
capacity problems at the moment some
people are reducing the quality of their
video conferencing services to reduce
strain on on services you're seeing some
websites take a bit longer obviously
things like home shopping and stuff are
completely under
total onslaught and people are putting
in queueing systems and all sorts of
things but on the whole actually the
internet itself is is coping remarkably
well it's really quite heartening I
should have said by the way another
worry about zoom is that a large portion
of its development is done in China
right and that's always a concern it's
not just a concern over zoom it's a
concern for you know we think that the
Huawei control versus there's been a lot
of controversy in the past about the
security of lenovo laptops for example
and to be fair Western governments and
Middle Eastern governments if they try
and sneak sneaky little spy systems into
their commercial software as well really
it's down to people to make a judgement
as to how they trust one nationality
over another as you pointed out take
your own security steps anyway
Adrian Mars always a pleasure and nice
to see you without a bookshelf behind
you something a little different for our
view